[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat et
avec tam tran huy cette semaine nous
sommes heureuses de recevoir françois
patriat bonjour bonjour et bienvenue et
cette âme qui dresse votre portrait
bonjour françois patriat jour vous êtes
sénateur de la côte d'or et vous
présidez le groupe rdp ir des pays pour
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant le groupe
de la majorité présidentielle au sénat
votre parcours vous a valu de passer du
statut de baron socialiste
solidement implanté dans vos terres de
bourgogne région d'ailleurs que vous
avez présidé pendant plus de dix ans à
celui d' outsider macro nice puisque
vous avez arraché votre réélection en
septembre dernier la majorité
présidentielle au sénat c'est en fait
une majorité très minoritaire 23
personnes sur 348 parlementaire est-ce
que vous avez parfois l'impression au
sénat d'être un peu seul contre tous ça
m'arrive souvent en effet parce que je
vois bien des coalitions un peu
hétéroclite entre les républicains les
socialistes parfois même les communistes
avec les républicains on voit bien qu'il
y à des oppositions des majorités de
circonstance
au delà de la majorité de droite du
sénat autour de tel ou tel sujet mais
elle est toujours la même
j'ai à dire je le regrette d'ailleurs un
moment nous avons besoin dans des
conditions telles connaissances d'un peu
d'unité nationale d'avoir des majorités
qui sont sur l'app pour à la fois
critique et pour essayer de mettre à mal
le gouvernement russe est pas le cas
aujourd'hui dans ce moment de gestion du
coc vidéo où on a eu une unité nationale
pendant au moins quelques mois au début
de la crise
pas vraiment politiquement on a eu dix
mythes et vous avez vu qu'il ya eu des
votes même contraire et des moments de
tension il ya eu quand même temps les
commission denquête on voit des traces
et dans ces circonstances là le groupe
air des pays avec l'europe en marche est
ultra minoritaire nous sommes 23
nous avons des élus socialistes de
bienveillance alliés potentiels
oui qu'ils avaient espéré des alliés
potentiels éventuellement claudien être
être marcheurs au sénat c'est être
protestant terre épiscopale allez on
peut aussi cette émission avec les
titres et le feu vert du sénat
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avec un changement par rapport
à la version de l'assemblée les
parlementaires ont raccourci l'état
d'urgence et l'ont ramené du 1er juin au
3 mai astrazeneca ne pourra pas tenir
ses engagements envers les pays
européens critiqués sur la campagne de
vaccination olivier vers en pointe du
doigt les dysfonctionnements dans les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques l'assemblée
s'attaque à la maltraitance animale la
proposition de loi débattu cette semaine
obtient un relatif consensus en écartant
les sujets qui fâchent comme la chasse à
courre où l'élevage intensif et pour
commencer cette émission le sénat
prolonge l'état d'urgence sanitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les sénateurs ont adopté la prorogation
mais en ont modifié la durée ils ont
raccourci d'un mois les débats se sont
tenues dans un climat serein avec un
ministre de la santé qui s'est dit
ouvert au dialogue sandra cerqueira feu
vert du sénat à une prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 3
mai un mois de moins que l'échéance
votée par l'assemblée nationale est
voulue par le gouvernement
olivier ferrand a présenté sans succès
des amendements pour tenter de rétablir
l'échéance du 1er juin la date du 1er
juin 2021
1 nous paraît cohérente au regard de la
dynamique de l'épidémie dans notre pays
et chez nos voisins et parce que c'est
le temps nécessaire pour que la campagne
de vaccination produisent pleinement ses
effets pour la droite majoritaire qui
défend des mesures plus territorialisée
dans la lutte contre le coc vide
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence se
justifie des modifications au projet de
loi ont tout de même été apportées comme
l'interdiction de limiter les réunions
dans les maisons au risque de heurter le
respect de la vie privée le vote d'une
mesure permettant au préfet de déroger à
la fermeture des commerces de détail et
enfin l'encadrement des mesures
d'isolement
si on maintient en quarantaine plus de
14 jours pendant plus de 12 heures par
jour des concitoyens parce qu'ils sont
contagieux il faut une décision du juge
des libertés le conseil constitué de
l'église l'exigent
j'ai pas d'inconvénient à l'écrire dans
la loi un état d'urgence prolongé pour
la sixième fois depuis mars 2020 la
gauche qui s'est abstenue lors du vote
alerte sur une atteinte aux libertés
publiques et une démocratie mise à mal
on ne saurait indifférent d'infiniment
mais tout un pays sous cloche
le risque d'accoutumance hurler gym
d'exception est bel et bien
elle conte régime d'exception qui finit
par s'en créé par la pratique dans le
droit commun n'est plus un régime
d'exception le sénat a en outre prévu
qu'au delà d'un mois
leur confinement devra être soumis au
vote du parlement et jeudi soir députés
et sénateurs ne sont pas parvenus à
s'entendre en commission mixte paritaire
l'objet de leur désaccord cette clause
par laquelle le sénat demandé à voter
chaque mois pour autoriser un éventuel
confinement à se poursuivre pas d'accord
en cmp françois patriat ce que c'était
trop demander que la représentation
nationale vote pour autoriser un
confinement à se poursuivre pourquoi ça
pose un problème que le majorité
sénatoriale a cherché à s'opposer
partiellement texte en disant qu'elle
était ouverte avec toute sa bonne
volonté mais qu'elle voulait à tout prix
ne pas avoir d'accord en cmp je les sens
sinon maintenant d'accord non mais je
veux dire que pour pâques est d'accord
le sénat ne voulait pas d'accord en cmp
en ne cédant pas parce que pourquoi
avancé d'un mois alors que tout les
tenez aujourd'hui permettent de penser
que l'épidémie va durer pendant le
printemps
nous sommes dans une situation difficile
potentiellement dramatiques
donc c'est une dépense de revoyure ce
que demande le sénat ce n'est pas
forcément pour voter contre ils ont
toujours accès dans l'obligation de
lever les clauses de revoyure pour
lesquels ils n'ont pas vous avez vu que
la clause de revoyure pour ce qui
concerne les élections ces cantonales et
régionales c'est sympa du tout halal
mais là le contrôle du parlement a exigé
la demande des parlementaires les
présidents j ai assisté hier à une
réunion avec le premier ministre et des
présidents de groupe où je vois que le
père de man 2 - d'être consultés zhili
présidente du groupe majoritaire du
sénat oui à part une ou deux remarques
sur la fermeture des écoles ou des
commerces n'ont pas fait de propositions
plus donc on demande à être consultés on
ne propose pas voilà je crois que le
texte du gouvernement étaient intactes
et les positions allaient servir de
possession lors du débat parlementaire
qu'il y aura sur un éventuel confinement
était promis d'ailleurs par jean castex
hier n'est ce pas le confirmer je vois
d'ici naître une future polémique hier
on conserve
je ne propose pas j'ai entendu j'ai
entendu le président du groupe
socialiste dire il faut prendre les
trains quand il passe je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire
nous n'avons pas de proposition à faire
à ce moment en dise qu'il y ait ce qu'on
nous dire à ce moment là pourquoi venez
vous nous demandez alors que le
président a déjà parlé et que les choses
sont en route
voyez bien qu'il ya quand même des
arrière-pensées très politique et je
vous le dis est ce que l'on sauvé non
confirmé qu'il y aura bien un débat
parlementaire et quant à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat sur un éventuel
confinement que d'abord il y aura demain
à conseil des fautes
samedi il y aura des décisions samedi il
y aura donc samedi aux côtés de défense
il y aura ensuite une décision qui sera
prise par le gouvernement
il y aura je ne lançais pas la date sans
doute il se doit intervenir une
allocution où une prise de parole par le
chef de l'état et dans les jours qui
suivront dans les heures qui suivront
parce que faudrait que ce débat il ait
lieu le plus rapidement possible avant
la mise en place
la mine est maigre brullemans de
confinement si ce confinement doit avoir
lieu donc ça veut dire dans les heures
après alors je ne sais pas quand le chef
de l'état aurait décidé de parler je ne
sais pas aujourd'hui quand vous voyez
les émeutes aux pays bas qui sont liées
au couvre-feu qu'envoyer tous les
mouvements de rébellion en espagne au
danemark
est ce que vous vous ne vous dites pas
justement que sur ce confinement il faut
réfléchir il faut pas forcément
restreindre un peu plus les libertés des
français quand on voit ce que cela peut
donner s'il n'ya pas d'acceptation de la
population
je vois comment on rappelle déjà
simplement un ici aux français quelle
est la situation
350 morts par jour dix mille mans par
mois gilmore par mois on les voit que ça
veut dire aujourd'hui donc c'est d'une
création dramatique c'est une partie de
la population qui est gravement en
danger aujourd'hui ça appelle donc des
mesures allaient mesure quand on pourra
vacciner plus on vaccine le plus
possible nous le souhaitons tous le
gouvernement aussi bien entendu en
attendant pour éviter une flambée
possible d'un scénario qui ressemblerait
ce qui se passe en iran ce qui s'est
passé en grande bretagne je crois que il
serait dramatique de ne pas prendre des
mesures suffisamment anticipé pour
qu'après vous vous le saviez vous auriez
dû
avant donc moi je suis aussi des dégâts
comme le chevreuil l on ait gamme
sickology car pour lui il faut pas les
premiers amis non bien sûr on doit les
prendre en compte bien entendu et on le
fait quand le ministre l'éducation
souhaite qu'on puisse ouvrir les écoles
que les étudiants suisses où est allé au
présentiel à jour par semaine comme chef
d'état s'y engager bien entendu qu'il ya
des problèmes psychologiques à des
problèmes économiques à l'épreuve de
pauvreté à côté il faut maintenant bien
cela mais maintenant tu en viens pour
vous les gars je parle alors je pense
que si on veut mettre en priorité comme
prime à la protection de la santé des
français
il ya des mesures difficiles que l'on
doit prendre aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je
dis désobéissance civile je n'y crois
pas beaucoup dans le pays je pense que
les français sont râleurs son bonheur ce
contestataire sans critique mais son va
même discipline sauf que les sondages
montrent qu'ils ne sont pas tout à fait
prêt à accepter un nouveau confinement
strict gr vu que ce matin là n'ont que
plus de 60% des français sont favorables
à nouveau confinement
mais quand on arrive au pied du mur vous
avez l'impression que l'opinion fini par
basculer en faveur des mesures
sanitaires vu de la somme d'informations
ne disposent les français la question
qu'il nous pose n'est pas de celle de
savoir est-ce qu'on va rencontrer mais
quand va t'on copine tessa et donc il ya
il ya une forme d'acceptation implicite
chez les français devant cette nouvelle
difficulté qu'il va falloir surmonter
est-ce que la situation sanitaire telle
que vous la voyez aujourd'hui l'état
d'urgence sanitaire qui a été prolongée
au moins jusqu'au 3 mai permet selon
vous de tenir les élections
départementales et régionales
fin juin moi je m'en tiens à la décision
qui a été prise
bien entendu je les voter et je la
soutiens
même si mon opinion personnelle à moi
était différente at-il mais à titre
personnel et je n'ai pas fait pression
sur le président de break quand il m'a
interrogé quant au consensus qu'il
recherchait je pense que les élections
se tiendront en juin deuxième quinzaine
de juin
quoi qu'il arrive elle ne pourrait être
modifiée que pour des raisons sanitaires
uniquement et pour aucune autre raison
autrement de façon à ce que ne soit pas
fait le reproche de vouloir magouilles
et traduire les élections à côté donc
elles ont lieu à ce moment-là les
personnels personnel moi j'étais miroir
pour plus pourquoi
parce que je pense ce fut d'abord que je
pense je suis sur dordogne presque
chaque semaine bien entendu je n'entends
pas les gens me réclamer à cor et à cri
des élections cantonales c'est pas leur
sujet deuxièmement démocratie non mais
d'accord c'est la démocratie mais c'est
que les conseillers j'ai vu des
sénateurs réélus 10 ans a ainsi tous les
dix ans on ne parlait pas à l'époque
quand on est passé de 9 à 10 ans
personne n'a eue relais qui avait plus
de démocratie bien et puis moi j'ai vu
les élections régionales et cantonales
des déjà repoussé d'ailleurs on les
repoussera en 2027 avec sa d'un an parce
qu'avec l'élection présidentielle ne les
repoussera demande envoyée moi je pense
d'abord un état sanitaire jolie la
campagne une campagne virtuelle qui
n'est pas une vraie campagne de pas
d'exigences civique aujourd'hui et 3 et
3 chacun des arrière pensées nous
pourrons nous take on me taxe est
d'avoir des arrières pensées de pousser
les quais entre eux mais est ce que la
droite aujourd'hui ici n'a pas d'arrière
pensée en volant les maintenir à tout
prix parce qu'elle craint qu emmanuel
macron ce que je pense sera réélu des
élections serait plus difficile après
allez on continue avec olivier ferrand
qui a défendu la campagne vaccinale lors
de la séance de questions d'actualité au
sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ministre des solidarités de la santé
a répété que si tous les laboratoires
tenu leurs engagements
la france serait en capacité de vacciner
70 millions de personnes fin août
mais dans le même temps il a aussi
pointé du doigt les retards déjà pris
par certains laboratoires et notamment
le laboratoire astrazeneca
regardez astrazeneca nous informe qu au
lieu de recevoir trois et quatre
millions de doses respectivement en
février mars ne recevront 2 million et 2
millions et demi
acte 2 que finalement les deux millions
de doses livrées au mois de février ce
sera d'abord 400 milles puis 700 milles
puis à la fin du mois un million et
quelques doses séparées pour la france
et pour toute l'europe
acte iii astrazeneca convoqué ce matin
devant des responsables de l'union
européenne a semble-t-il quitté la
réunion
ce qui n'est en général pas très bon
signe et acte iv enfin que j'ai appris
pendant votre séance de questions au
gouvernement
astrazeneca aurait communiqué sur son
incapacité de fournir davantage qu'un
tiers ou un quart des doses à l'europe
d'ici à la fin du premier trimestre
raison pour laquelle à la sénatrice
j'étais prudent la semaine dernière en
disant que je ne suis pas certain qu'on
aurait vacciner tous les publics
fragiles avant l'été mais raison pour
laquelle je rappelle que factuellement
nous avons passé des commandes qui
engage les fabricants de vaccins qui se
sont engagés contractuellement et
consignés pour fournir aux états les
vaccins qu'ils ont produit alors
françois patriat quand on parle à
olivier vers ans de retard dans la
campagne de vaccination incombe est
plutôt en cause de gouvernement ils nous
répondent en parlant beaucoup des
dysfonctionnements des laboratoires ce
que c'est pas un peu facile non alors le
bord un instant en arrière
souvenez-vous première semaine de
janvier on nous ait dit jamais vous ne
tiendrez vos engagements ça patine ça ne
fonctionne pas le gouvernement avait dit
un million un million de fin janvier
fin janvier un million cinq cent mille
personnes ont reçu un million cinq plus
que les objectifs affichés
maintenant l'objectif affiché pour la
fin février c'est 2 millions 400 mille
personnes ont reçu au moins une première
injection en fonction des apports qui
sont là aujourd'hui je dis pas que c'est
pas fait le poids de leur vessie et
brise ne se pose pas avec les deux mille
ans cathy avec ce qui est prévue
aujourd'hui avec avec les données avec
les nouvelles donnes et astrazeneca y
avec les nouvelles données pêche
car les esprits quand louis ne ferait
pas vu les retards qui ont sont déjà
rentrées non est ce qu'on va voir 70
millions fin où ça va être quand même
compliqué le 2000 non les knicks trappe
à l'opa je crois que l'objectif ou que
je considère plus juste c'est celui des
15 millions vacciner à la fin du
printemps
aujourd'hui alors faut pas comparer les
chiffres les deux pays c'est la
stratégie c'est ce que la stratégie est
bonne je pense que les royaume uni n'a
pas une bonne stratégie qu ils alors
qu'une seule injection qu'ils vaccinent
pas les personnes qu'il faut absolument
vacciner et que je ne doute pas qu'à
terme la stratégie européenne et
française soit la meilleure donc voila
moi je me fixe comme objectif 15
millions les personnes les plus fragiles
à la fin du thé pour la fin d'août
on verra ensuite mais je pense que les
difficultés de production aujourd'hui
les arrière pensées je vois si certains
laboratoires
mais pour y remédier c'est un l'exigence
de notre pays 2 la fermeté européenne et
le centre de démontrer aujourd'hui alors
justement l'europe elle s'est targué
d'avoir négocié des contrats et de
pouvoir retourner se retourner contre
les laboratoires est ce que vous croyez
qu'il faut aller en justice si toutefois
astrazeneca ne livre pas les doses
promises
je crois que astrazeneca son s'engagera
à livrer les doses avec ald avec un
décalage aujourd'hui d'abord il est
évident que les doses produites en
europe ne doivent pas repartir au
royaume uni aujourd'hui je pense que je
pense mais c'était il ya des soucis ça a
été évoqué ya des soupçons
donc là je crois que la commission
européenne prend les mesures pour
enquêter pour vérifier que ces vaccins
restent bien 3 est la raison d'être
exigeante la commission parce qu'il ya
de l'argent public et l'argent européen
pour ces laboratoires qui ont bénéficié
de man extraordinaire pour faire la
recherche il se développer leurs
arguments aujourd'hui et sans doute pour
certains de bonne foi d'autres de
mauvaise foi c'est à la commission d'en
déterminer et avec tous les toits que je
pense que vous avez vu le fait qu'ils
aient quitté la réunion et ailleurs
montre qu'il ya quand même une
difficulté de leur part et je crois que
la fermeté l'autorité paiera au bout du
compte aller en mars avril on aura les
deux vous avez l'impression quand même
que dans toute cette histoire l'union
européenne est en train de se faire
avoir et que le laboratoire astrazeneca
est en train de privilégier le marché
britannique par rapport aux marchés
européens aujourd'hui
je vous ai déjà pour partiellement
répondu les anglais pour commander un
peu plus tôt que nous deux ou trois mois
plus tôt ils ont payé beaucoup plus cher
aujourd'hui
alors je vous comprends bien l'arrière
pensée du laboratoire d'aller faire plus
d'argent chez eux aujourd'hui de prime
d'abord on a trôné au bord de l'eau à
l'abricot local non non non mais je
pense qu'au contraire nan mais imaginez
qu'on ait négocié chaque pays séparément
et ses laboratoires dans quelle
situation de faiblesse on se trouverait
aujourd'hui c'est parce que l'europe
parle d'une seule voix avec des
commandes fermes et qu'elle sera je
crois faire preuve dans cette fermeté
qu'elle gagnera le mas et fermeté pour
faire en sorte que tous les engagements
soient tenus il ya quand même deux
laboratoires notamment français sanofi
pasteur qui n'ont pas pu développer ce
vaccin ils ont reçu beaucoup d'être de
l'état est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
normal que la recherche française soit 6
à la traîne aujourd'hui
non d'abord sanofi a dit qu difficultés
que c'est avec son avec son vaccin mais
dans le même temps ils réparent est pour
partie cette difficulté en prenant en
charge la fabrication de vaccins pfizer
sur le territoire des vingt ans on se
connaît suffisamment dons qui vont
fabriquer je trouve que comme c'est pas
6 à gisela menée sous très sympa à
séparer la deuxième chose
saler la recherche française a montré
depuis longtemps qu'elle était quand
même à très haut niveau avec à la fois
ces chercheurs et ses réussites
lassitude pasteur n'a pas eu un seul
vaccin ce qu'elle recherche
elle recherche sur beaucoup d'autres
choses aujourd'hui folie trithérapie au
tout ça s'est quand même retrouvé dans
le temps dans ce laboratoire la france
quand on paye pour la recherche allait
paye pas toujours pour gagner ça suffit
pas sûr on a fait des mauvais soirs donc
voilà non massa juges jugent pas à lui
je cherche heures et ils ont leurs
pistes visant leur voix mais penser que
parce qu'on donne de l'argent à leur
charge gothique motifs m'en trouver donc
il ya des startups qui retrouver qu'avec
qui avait sans doute des chercheurs plus
pointues dans différents modèles mais je
ne condamne à rien aucun cas aujourd'hui
leurs recherches on s'est jeté l'opprobe
sur la recherche française d'aujourd'hui
qui est un très bon niveau très haut
niveau c'est ça fait partie de ceux ne
sommes pas chez nous parce que la france
est ce qu'on aime bien faire voilà elle
et on termine avec l'assemblée qui se
penche sur la maltraitance des animaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une proposition de loi de la majorité
examiné cette semaine dans l'hémicycle
vise à lutter contre la maltraitance
animale elle veut interdire
progressivement les animaux sauvages
dans les cirques où les delphinariums et
encadrer davantage l'achat d'animaux
domestiques car si la france est le
premier pays à adopter elle est aussi le
premier pays à les abandonner
les précisions dels monts à gaza avant
d'acquérir un char un chien ou tout
autre animal de compagnie
vous devrez signer un certificat de
connaissances il vous rappellera les
obligations de soins de vaccination et
les coûts liés à la possession d'un
animal
une façon de responsabiliser les futurs
propriétaires
une des mesures phare de la proposition
de loi aujourd'hui aucune connaissance
près là pas la moindre connaissance
préalable est exigé pour acquérir un
animal de compagnie on sait que c'est la
première étape avant des difficultés de
vie commune qui vont se finir par un
divorce assez rapide
la vente de chat ou de chien au en
animalerie sera prohibée d'ici à 2024
les députés ont par ailleurs encadrer la
vente en ligne d'animaux de compagnie en
la réservant au refuge et aux éleveurs
concernant les animaux sauvages cette
fois ils seront interdits dans les
cirques ou encore dans les discothèques
le texte durcit les sanctions en cas de
maltraitance trois ans d'emprisonnement
et 45000 euros damende si elle entraîne
la mort de l'animal pour parvenir à un
consensus
la majorité a délibérément choisi de ne
pas aborder certains sujets jugés trop
polémiques comme la chasse à courre la
corrida ou encore l'élevage intensif ce
que lui reprochent certains dans les
oppositions
nous ne parlerons donc d'aucun de ces
sujets
car en marche considère que tout ceci
est hors sujet dans une loi qui vise à
lutter contre la maltraitance animale
alors oui cette loi est bienvenu car les
animaux sont trop mal traités en france
mais elle est hypocrite et
volontairement incohérente pour cette
proposition de loi ce qui fait débat
c'est donc surtout ce qu'il n'y a pas
dans le texte
françois patriat avec cette proposition
là la majorité à éviter les sujets qui
fâchent la chasse à courre l'élevage
intensif est ce qu'elle ne va pas rater
sa cible
non je crois que christophe castaner a
soutenu ce texte c'est un texte en tant
que vétérinaire
par ailleurs je soutiens aussi même si j
des nuances sur les propositions qui
sont faites
il est certain qu'il y a des problèmes
de maltraitance animale dans notre pays
il ya aussi des problèmes dans le
commerce des animaux commerce licite
illicite qu'il faut règlementer
aujourd'hui une éducation pour les
propriétaires d'animaux je suis
vétérinaire mais j'ai un chien et chat
qu'il quitte qui est nécessaire parce
que c'est vrai qu'on veut faire plaisir
un enfant on achète un chat pour moins
cher et après on abandonne donc ce texte
de loi est volontairement
moi je suis pour la politique des petits
pas les grands pas les grands solides
rendements sanitaires et vous légiférer
sur les animaux domestiques quelle
société mais qui vous a pas échappé que
c'était un sujet traité j'entends bien
alors faut-il arrêter de légiférer sur
tous les dossiers à côté c'est pas mais
c'est un sujet comme je rappelle que le
party animal il a fait plus de plus que
le bayer communiste aux élections que ce
qu'est ce qu'il s'agit pas aussi d'un
peu épaissie un bilan sur ce sujet
désormais très grand public vous le
dites on voit que ça fait énormément
parler les français tout ça à 14 mois de
l'élection présidentielle
c'est une proposition de l'eau atteint
dès lé mal du parlement après tout on
peut pas dire d'un côté que le parlement
ne peut pas s'exprimer et au le jour la
majorité dans le parlement ce serait des
propositions de l'album vous faites un
peu de politique ça va essayer mais ce
que j'ai entendu je ne fais que ça
m'intéresserait mais si müller ou est-ce
qui s'il n'y a pas une fois zone mans de
proposition de loi au sénat sur des
sujets tout à fait secondaire par
rapport à la situation
moi je crois que le le fourmillement des
propositions de loi le met pas débat sur
ce texte de loi
je préfère une loi qui avancent qu'une
loi qui va rester sans suite parce que
si effectivement on avait abordé le
problème de l'élevage intensif
on voit bien le débordement le problème
de la chasse à courre voyez la corrida
vous le voyez
dans les modes dans l'émotionnel
globalement et la loi n'aurait pas
abouti
elle aurait pas été volé quatre vingts
pour cent des français sont opposés à la
chasse à courre c'est un sondage ifop
pour la fondation et la chose bardot à
l'achat d'un abonnement à la chasse à
courre l'âme précisément mais peut-être
la chasse aussi vous ménager les
chasseurs n'ont pas du tout été moi je
suis chasseur le sait c'est que c'est
clair aujourd'hui je pense que le débat
autour de la chasse est irrationnel
canton erreurs à le contourner urba on
peut comprendre quand on est né dans une
famille de chasseurs ce qui est mon cas
on peut comprendre quand on est né à
paris dans une vie dans une ronde il
était rare qu'on n'a jamais connu la
chasse c'est qu'on ne connaît pas la
nature par ailleurs
sinon pensez que la nature appartient à
tout le monde alors qu'elle n'appartient
pas tout le monde par ailleurs c'est un
sujet plus difficile est un sujet
extrêmement qui mérite du débat de la
pédagogie
j'allais dire un peu de sérénité mais
vous avez cette dernière s'est
d'ailleurs les français non sans poils
interdit pensais pas qu'il faudrait
quand même à terme un t3 de la chasse la
chasse cruelle à la chasse à courre le
déterrage réfléchir quand même aller à
la chasse à la glu qui est juste
suspendu peut-être faudra-t-il
l'interdire ou l'élevage intensif comme
ça il faut pas quand même un des textes
pour vraiment y réfléchir parce que je
sais que c'est le doigt dans l'engrenage
d'une partie de la population qui veut
voir disparaître les chasseurs en france
aujourd'hui on commence par la chasse à
courre
on commence par les chasses
traditionnelles les chasses
traditionnelles concerne deux mille
personnes en france aujourd'hui autour
d'une chose qui ne tue pas par ailleurs
que je ne pratique pas que je n'apprécie
pas mais que je défends par ailleurs et
qu'on peut sur lesquels on peut discuter
je sais que là je vais être en désaccord
avec beaucoup de gens sur ce sujet mais
je crois que sur ce sujet y compris pour
les animaux dans les cirques aujourd'hui
on fait un tabou animaux dans les
cirques s'anime quand on connaît la
réalité 2
il se permet aux gens de voir des
animaux qui ne verront jamais qui sont
plutôt bien traités par ailleurs donc
voilà c'est très drôle
et moi je pense qu'il faut pas légiférer
sur tout tout le temps mais que plus tôt
il faut dialoguer moi je suis le
dialogue entre les promeneurs et les
chasseurs je le pratique tous les
dimanches le prête avec la population je
le fais et quand ou si vous allez à la
campagne dans les villages et vous voyez
aujourd'hui c'est que représente la
chasse dans le territoire rural en
particulier on n'aura pas cette réaction
essentiellement citadine l214 a alerté
fréquemment sur les dérives de l'élevage
intensif l'élevage en cage
vous vous pensez qu'il ya pas de
problème de ce côté-là je pense qu'un
problème de financement de l214 où l 214
trouve beaucoup d'argent aujourd'hui des
grands magnats de l'industrie qui
aujourd'hui voulait voir voudrait voir
disparaître la consommation qui
redevient engrais animal pour consommer
de la viande et des produits végétaux et
qui ont des gros intérêts des lobbys
clariant sait ce que vaut ce que vaut
penser aujourd'hui qu'il ya des
associations qui touche beaucoup
d'argent il comprit d'argent de l'état
pour venir ensuite défendre les intérêts
et les intérêts donc moi sur l 214 je
suis très désolé l'agencé mais ce pas
trop les niveaux la toile on a déjà
remédié vous savez pour les poules
pondeuses pour les établissements pour
qui a déjà aujourd'hui
ne vous imaginez pas moi qui vit avec
les paysans tous les jours le nombre des
forfaits le monde
aujourd'hui le monde de l'élevage pour
améliorer les conditions d'élevage de la
jeter l'opprobe comme le furent des
associations qui parfois même fond du
complotisme trucs des images
yann est vrai bien entendu ils sont
dénoncés elles sont arrêtées mais voilà
donc j'ai beaucoup de réserves vis-à-vis
aujourd'hui de l214 et bien merci merci
beaucoup françois patriat d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci
brigitte on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]